there's something absolutely hilarious
going on that is taking over the life of
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell and it's the nickname Moscow
Mitch the nickname Moscow Mitch is
sticking to McConnell like bad ideas
stick to Republicans and he just cannot
get away from it now the reason he's
being called Moscow Mitch they're
actually numerous reasons one is that he
keeps blocking every single election
security bill that's meant to prevent
foreign interference in our elections
including from countries like Russia
which we know interfered in 2016 and
over the weekend a crowd chanting Moscow
Mitch - Mitch McConnell so loudly that
it drowned him out for a significant
portion of the audience this was at some
kind of picnic event in fancy farm
Kentucky and it was hilarious the mics
are close to McConnell here so you'll
hear McConnell but you'll start to hear
the chanting coming from the back the
only one not in New York or California
I'm the guy that sticks up for middle
America and for Kentucky I've saved the
Supreme Court I just love it
McConnell increasingly struggling to be
heard over the Moscow Mitch chanting the
hill TV host and political consultant
crystal ball was at this event and
posted video to her social media that
she took and she's a little bit further
back in the crowd you can't even hear
McConnell back there because of the
Moscow Mitch chants
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it is absolutely delightful that this is
catching on and it should catch on given
what he's done he's blocked the duty to
report Act which would require
presidential campaigns to report to the
FBI offers of assistance from foreign
countries something Donald Trump
recently said yeah I don't know i would
take the help in 2020 from China or
Russia I don't know if I'd actually
report it to the FBI there was a bill
that would require that reporting
McConnell blocked it
McConnell blocked the securing America's
Federal Elections Act which has been
passed by the house it would direct six
hundred million dollars in election
assistant assistance to States and
require paper backup ballots there was a
bipartisan bill which would have
required companies like Facebook and
Google to disclose who is buying
political ads in order to suss out
foreign influence McConnell blocked that
there was a bipartisan bill to ease
cooperation between state election
officials and federal Intel agencies
McConnell blocked it McConnell blocked a
bipartisan bill imposing sanctions on
entities that attack a US election
McConnell blocked a bipartisan vil bill
with new sanctions on Russia for its
cyber crimes and it's been one after
another after another and here is the
sort of segue that I think is the most
important one for us here
Moscow Mitch has an opponent in 2020 Ami
McGrath Moscow Mitch could be removed in
2020 from his Senate seat Moscow Mitch
isn't that popular in Kentucky his
opponent is someone you can support and
is someone that you can donate to it's
Amy McGrath look her up I've talked
about her before there is an opportunity
here to remove I mean in addition to Ted
Cruz one of the most disgusting members
of the US Senate
but unlike Ted Cruz McConnell has been
much more effective and efficient at
actually getting really horrible things
done for the Republican Party hey if you
want to see a hilarious hate mail that I
got follow me on instagram at david
pakman did it there this morning and
while you're there follow
the David Pakman show as well on
instagram at david pakman show let's
take a quick break so much more to talk
about right after this